hey everyone it's tony here with
alessandro and alessandro you just got
to check out some shadow warrior three
yeah this is the the next one from uh
flying wild hog
and uh it's coming from devolver digital
as well and uh we
got to see more of the game during that
really crazy
you know sort of like e3 presentation
and we also got a bit of an extended
look after that too like
we saw about 20 minutes or so of
gameplay it looks a lot like doom like
this kind of just feels like ninja doom
in a way
yeah basically and i think a big part of
that is because they've added a new
grappling hook
uh traversal has obviously been a big
part of these games like the second game
added
you're climbing you're double jumping
now we've got a grappling hook to swing
all around so
tell me what that's like using that the
grappling hook is the new thing
that will for one actually allow you to
you know sort of move around like you
know
certain like uh sections of the levels
but also using combat as well so
you can actually grapple onto like
certain objects like explosive barrels
there's a lot more focus on sort of like
blending these different skills together
yeah i saw kind of a get over here
scorpion kind of move
in the gameplay where low pulled over uh
an
enemy closer so that he could shoot them
it's got that same energy actually it's
like it crossed between like mortal
kombat and doom really like you know
it's got that
sort of very like high flying you know
very action oriented like energy to it i
mentioned
uh low wang just a moment ago of loan of
course being the hero of these games
uh and if we're talking doom like is he
still
kind of a caricature doom guy kind of
type in this game or
are they kind of fleshing him out more
as a character for this one
i'd say they're actually flashing him
out a bit more with this game um i
actually got to speak with uh one of the
creative leads at flying wild hog uh
paul
kawaluski and uh he uh stated that they
wanted to
make it seem like that uh lil wang was
not only more of a character this time
around we're actually getting to know
more
about him and you know you know being
more comfortable with his sort of like
playfulness but
he's uh he's actually something a bit
more like a fanboy you know just sort of
like really having fun
in you know the in the experience he's
um
there's one moment in like the demo we
saw where uh like r b
music came in like it was a really fun
moment it's got like uh
it's got like strong like deadpool
energy to it are you in doubt we can do
this
kill a dragon as big as a mountain with
a halloween mask
damn right though personally i'd rather
have a battle cruiser with photon
torpedoes
it was cool seeing him like you know
sort of become more of like a character
instead of a caricature because um
you know i'd be remiss not to bring this
up but um the original uh
shadow warrior actually sort of relied
pretty heavily on like sort of these
very antiquated and you know pretty
offensive stereotypes
these games have certainly made that
change to luang as a character but this
third one
it's also kind of making a change to the
way the levels are designed right yes
uh i can say that this game is moving
closer to what the original reboot
the shadow warrior reboot was about the
second game actually
experimented a bit with uh you know sort
of like this loot system and uh
also brought in randomly generated like
levels
for this game they're gonna be moving
away from that entirely and just going
back to the more like handcrafted
like a singular spaces they're going
more for like the story driven
like experience and uh also a single
player experience because there's
actually going to be no co-op at this
time around as well
so the game is entirely single-player
that's totally fine that's their
prerogative
but they are still remixing combat in
other ways right
you said there's no loot system but you
can still like acquire weapons from the
enemies kind of
yeah um so each weapon in the game is
very much like handcrafted like you know
there's less redundancy in the weapons
you can acquire in the game because
the second game like had i think over 70
weapons and
uh you know they can you can find like
so many variables
like swords and stuff so uh each weapon
in the game is very much
like a thing you can actually acquire
from like the story missions or
actually from combat encounters
themselves which uh
you know during like several moments you
can actually um pull off these finishers
like on
enemies and you can actually pull out a
weapon from them like my my favorite
enemy actually from the demo was like
this sort of like weird like
jack-in-the-box
looking enemy like you and you can
actually sort of tear it open and pull
out this
fireworks launcher and you can actually
use it against other enemies in the area
it sort of gives it like sort of like
this sort of like an arcadey vibe to it
where you get these pickups that you can
actually
use for a limited time to actually take
out all the enemies in the area
and um one thing i i did like is that
you know the
they seem to be applying these sort of
doom 2016 or doom eternal
sort of philosophy of the combat puzzle
so each encounter actually uh has you
facing off with all these different
enemies and you need to figure out the
best way to actually sort of take them
out
by either using these sort of like
pickup weapons from
that you get from fallen enemies or even
the traps and uh one of
one really cool trap is like there's
this like row of buzz saws like going
through
the environment you can actually push
enemies into them and you know it's
uh it sort of creates these really
gnarly encounters that you know looked
like just really fantastic kind of seems
like those puzzly encounters go hand in
hand with the
handcrafted level design then it
definitely uh echoes that of the
original reboot but it's still got some
of that uh sort of the just extremely
over the top energy from the second game
as well so
in a lot of ways it's sort of like a
happy mix between the first and second
uh shadow warrior it's something that
i'm really looking forward to seeing
more because i want to see like how far
they can push
well speaking of seeing more when can
people get their hands on this so right
now
shadow warrior 3 is currently planned
for a 2021 release on pc
and uh they haven't said anything about
consoles yet so
we'll hopefully hear more about that
obviously we have the new
ps5 and xbox series x coming out this
year so uh you know i wouldn't be
surprised if we
see shadow warrior three on those uh
consoles as well i wouldn't be surprised
either so stay tuned to gamespot we will
certainly report on those announcements
if they happen
and stay tuned for more shadow warrior
three coverage
[Music]
you